So, we talked about domain, we've talked about range, we've talked about how we
can impose domain restrictions on functions, depending on the situations in the
real world that they're involved in, and we've talked about overall function
behavior. However, I still want to dig deeper. Let's take a look at this
function, g of x equals the square root of x. Now remember, that we just have a
radical sign and no sign in front of it, it's implied that this is the positive
square root, this is not a plus or minus thing. Let's take a look at the graph
of this function. So, here's our graph of g of x equals the square root of x.
Now, I could describe its behavior by saying that it's increasing from 0 to
infinity. But let's think back to the domain. So, what do you think the domain
of g of x is? All numbers between what and what?